bei der nächsten geschichte da läuft es
mir ehrlich gesagt kalt den rücken
runter und das liegt an diesem killer
ehepaar auf dem foto zu sehen sind mba
und tanja w auf dem hauptbahnhof in
hannover
in dem koffer ist ein japanisches kopf
kampfmesser eine zersägte schaufel und
sachen von kaviar den hat embraer vorher
mit genau diesem messer umgebracht und
in dem koffer zum friedhof gebracht die
leiche haben die beiden dann dort
verscharrt
seit mai sitzen die beiden in u-haft und
haben mittlerweile auch schon die tat
gestanden
mehr zu dem fall weiß jetzt mein kollege
mirko voltmer er kennt den fall wie
gesagt sehr genau
mirko warum musste denn gerade das opfer
sterben war dass ein gezielter anschlag
sozusagen also die mordkommission hier
in hannover geht momentan davon aus dass
das motiv rache war
dazu muss man ausführen tanja w hat der
verkäufer in bielefeld war anfang 2009
10 oder davor in einen dating portal im
internet kennengelernt
unter einem pseudonym die beiden sollen
sich getroffen haben und dabei soll es
angeblich zu einem übergriff von kaviar
gekommen sein
die sache wurde nie aufgeklärt auch die
ermittlung dazu eingestellt
das war trotzdem anlass führt anja w
offensichtlich und auch für ihren neuen
freund nämlich ändere sich dann an
kaviar rächen zu wollen selbstjustiz zu
verüben
und sie haben ihn dann in hannover zu
ihrer unterkunft
es ist eine diakonische unterkunft weil
das pärchen unter dem asperger-syndrom
leidet dann in dieses haus gelockt und
dort getötet
und jetzt muss man ja sagen am tag
selbst war die polizei noch bei den
mutmaßlichen tätern was hat es damit auf
sich
ja das ist der anwalt der opferfamilie
bzw
familie ist ob was pascal ackermann
sagte also katastrophaler kann ein
einsatz ein wenig verlaufen
tatsächlich hat emrah nachdem er
kg aa getötet haben sollen getötet hatte
eine erste etage den rettungsdienst
gerufen
und zwar weil er sich offensichtlich mit
dem messer selbst verletzt hatte
der rettungsdienst kam auch und der ging
nach draußen vor der tür
parallel dazu hat aber eine bewohnerin
des hauses die schreie gehört hat
ebenfalls die polizei alarmiert und die
kam dann auch mit zwei streifenwagen und
traf draußen auf das pärchen und fragen
erkundigten sich natürlich was da los
sei und emre hat es tatsächlich
geschafft die beamte von zu überzeugen
das ist nicht naja unfall gewesen ist er
hätte sich bei samurai tricks mit einem
schwert verletzt
die beamten zogen dann wieder von dannen
sie haben tatsächlich nochmal im
erdgeschoss kurz nachgefragt bei einem
nachbarn sind aber nicht mehr hoch zur
wohnung von m real gegangen
da hätten sie dann vielleicht kaviar
gefunden